[Musique]
par notre travail et notre intelligence
nous produisons deux fois plus de
richesses que nous le faisions en 1981
et pourtant on ne peut plus aller nulle
part dans le pays sans voir des gens
dormir sur le trottoir ou dans leur
voiture
il y a huit millions de pauvres dont 3
millions de travailleurs
comment vivre dignement quand on doit se
demander si on va payer le loyer ou se
soigner si l'on va nourrir les enfants
ou régler la facture d'électricité
voyons aussi ces femmes ces hommes
obligés de travailler le dimanche ou
honoraires discontinues
comment s'occuper alors des enfants et
profiter avec eux d'un peu de bonheur
simple
et que dire des jeunes qui mettent en
moyenne plus de 10 ans pour trouver un
emploi stable si l'on ne pouvait pas
faire autrement
peut-être se résigne letton mais ceci
n'est pas une fatalité
c'est la conséquence directe du refus
des puissants de partager les richesses
en 30 ans 10 points de ce qui est
produit dans notre pays est passé des
poches des travailleurs à celle des
actionnaires
cela représente 200 milliards d'euros
par an avec le front de gauche je
propose de les récupérer
dès mon élection je porterai le smic à
1700 euros brut
cela représente une augmentation de deux
euros par heure de travail
les libéraux nous explique déjà que
c'est trop mais qui nous explique
comment alors on peut vivre avec 1000 94
euros par mois le front de gauche
propose aussi la mise en place d'un
salaire maximum dans chaque entreprise
le salaire le plus haut ne pourra pas
dépasser 20 fois le salaire le plus bas
cela laisse encore de la marge mais pour
ceux qui mentent et le dirigeant devra
aussi augmenter celui qui est en bas de
l'échelle
nous voulons enfin créer un revenu
maximum autorisé dans le pays
pas plus de 360 milles euros par
personne une société démocratique ne
peut pas tolérer un enrichissement sans
limite
l'effort fiscal sera lissé car il y aura
14 tranche pour l'impôt il sera bien
progressif ainsi il ménagera les
classements
vous le voyez avec de la volonté on peut
partager les richesses de l'argent il y
en a ce qu'il faut c'est le mettre au
service de tous
[Musique]
oh